self-driving cars and the taxi service I
think this is uh despite um setbacks
this this is one of I think most
promising uses in my my opinion of of
technology that uh impacting the real
world and and uh um very happy that or
coin has uh agreed to speak to us sure
just maybe some help yeah so or not to
be funny but is your parking okay for
today because I have these
parking
[Laughter]
I don't want
toer so today yeah I'll talk I'll give
you a brief overview of what data
scientists do at Cruz it's pretty
different than everything you heard
today uh and I'll try to dive a little
deeper into some of the problems that my
team at Cruz is working on um which are
related to vehicle routing that we just
heard about um and again data scientists
like me we don't work on the more
autonomy side that you hear about like
these are mostly machine learning
Engineers um but data scientists still
do a lot of important things at Cruz um
so there are two areas of data science
at Cruz um which are like one is like
autonomy that data scientists that are
helping the autonomous uh autonomy teams
are developing this software on the car
uh measure stuff measure metrics and so
on and there's the other side which I'll
talk more about is commercial data
science so once you have these cars
these Robo taxi on the road how do you
create you know a a a commercial service
out of them so autonomy in there are
areas of data science that we help you
know the autonomy teams a lot in
measuring safety and reliability so you
know our cars drive around in the city
but they don't have a lot of access
incidents happening and so we need to
create this kind of like dense metrics
that um compute basically based on some
like near near accidents compute how you
know safe and reliable our car is and do
it you know with very limited driving so
you know we have a version of our
software we test it for a few weeks with
this kind of supervised Fleet of of U
cars and you need to decide whether this
new version is safe enough to release to
the road with driverless cars without
any
supervision and so data science help
with that also creating this kind of
Safety Human Benchmark so we have you
know accident data about humans we want
we want to prove that we are safer than
humans so data scientists help creating
this kind of Benchmark in every city uh
how what's the average rate of accidents
uh for humans and also in simulation
testing so we have a lot of investment
done on simulation um and so data
scientists help in creating these kind
of important sampl technique curating
test cases for the source simulation so
every software version we're releasing
want to test them in simulator we need
to you know pick the right scenarios
that are more risky uh in order to know
that we are better um and then use that
to understand what's our overall safety
level before again we release a version
of the software to the road so these are
autonomy team data science these are
supporting autonomy team and my team
supports the commercial sites so once we
have this kind of like nice app uh there
are many areas where data science is
helping you know make it better and
create a commercial product that is you
know viable um so there are many
challenges that on the data science side
we Face a lot of them are pretty typical
challenges that Uber and Lyft on you
know in other reld companies around the
world you know face like how you match a
ride with request how you route vehicles
um how do you predict etas um how you
price these are pretty similar but then
we have these kind of like new
challenges that come from the fact that
we are actually controlling these
vehicles uh you know 247 what they do on
the road what they do inside facilities
and when they get stuck there's no human
driver that can you know get them out of
you know tricky situations so that
creates a lot of challenges for us that
and also a lot of interesting
algorithmic problems and I want to now
dive a little bit into a few problems
that uh we're facing and how we are
right now approaching them but
definitely there's still a lot of work
to be done in these areas um so let's
start with like going into positioning
so positioning typically this means how
do we you know position our vehicles
before we get a ride so we want to make
sure that our you know once we put the
vehicles on the road we want to make
sure that they are going to be position
where we expect to have rise occurring
um and so typically at over what you
would do instead of positioning you
creating this kind of like driver
incentive you create incentives for the
vehicles for the drivers to go to high
demand zones here at Cru we have higher
control and the algorithmic problem is
actually very different um and so there
are many works in the Academia you can
find about how to do vehicle positioning
here I'm proposing I'm showing just one
solution that we're taking and there are
still challenges and I'm going to talk
about the remaining challenges but one
solution that can be done is basically
to describe this kind of like divide the
city into this kind of Zone here we have
San Francisco divided into three zones
um and then we basically Define this
kind of a graph where every Point here
represents a Zone and this is time and
so we discretize time as well and then
we Define this kind of um you know we
Define how many vehicles are here at
time zero and we we want to solve for
the rate of transition between every
Zone and every at every moment in time
and we add on top of that these kind of
like edges where these are customer
trips so if a you know we have a trip
here and we expect to have demand and
this demand basically takes can take one
vehicle up to you know some some
different Zone it could be actually a
different Zone um should be a different
Zone and um and at a different time and
so this basically you can take this
problem take put in your demand put in
uh all your zones and you can solve it
using a linear program to get these
rates of transition the rates of
transition at time equals zero basically
tell you whether you need to move
vehicles from Zone one to zone two or
other zes so this is pretty simple but
there's like a more interesting
challenge if how do you combine this you
know problem along with the matching so
matching I'm going to match a vehicle
with you know match a vehicle with ride
at this time but sometimes it makes
sense to take into account positioning
so let's say I have a request you know
right in the Border do I match it with a
vehicle from here or from here if they
have very similar etas and if I know
that I need more vehicle idling here
then here then I want to match to this
zone so you can get extra efficiency by
combining the matching problem and the
positioning problem and this is
something we're still you know in the
works but if you look you can find
different solutions a reinforcement
learning solution is also possibility
here um and so a different interesting
problem is how to deal with charging and
maintenance so we have we positioning
the vehicles but then we need to un
decide when do we want to send vehicles
to charge
and or to get them maintained and when
when do you want to deploy them to the
you know to the stream um and here again
we want to make sure that we have all
the vehicles available when we have the
peak demand and we don't want to you
know waste you know of our you know our
charge basically our electricity when we
have no demand so again this is a work
we did uh with an intern from Stanford
um last year but basically you can do a
similar thing that what we said I
proposed previously you have these kind
of like zones and you have time so
discretize time and you have
discretizing space you add to this also
these kind of like facilities where we
are charging our vehicles and you also
discre tide charge levels and you can
then put everything and optimize
everything using again a linear program
to get this kind of like Optimal
deployment schedule where you want to
you know deploy your vehicles and you
can try to follow that you know using
the realtime system so there's a lot of
you know remaining uh challenges of how
to basically compute this schedule and
you know update it in real time as you
know the condition on the roads change
uh but this is the basic solution that
for now like we've prototyped along with
the
in um so this like interesting this is a
very different problem than what you
know traditionally Uber and LIF people
are dealing with uh and there still uh
you know challenges remaining there um
other areas that are like somewhat
different is for instance that you don't
think so much about is like choosing a
pickup and drop off point so our AVS
can't really stop everywhere right now
there's a lot of places where you know
it's not really safe and human drivers
are able to stop and you know block you
know someone's garage we can't do that
um and so we we need to be safe we need
to be you know legal and there are other
consideration that take into account so
optimizing where we're going to stop and
pick you up is really important for us
much more than for traditional rill uh
companies and so we taking we want to
take into account multiple consideration
when determining that and would be the
walking time of course but also there
there's a trip time so how long it would
take to get you to your home and how
long would you have to wait so choosing
different spots May mean that there's
like different uh you know driving time
from your AV to your spot and there's
the probability that actually we won't
be able to stop at this spot and then
we'll choose a different one um and
there's also you know how much we'll be
impeding traffic you want to make sure
that we choose a spot where we're
impeding less traffic creating less of
an issues for other drivers and so
taking all of this into account is you
know a challenging problem and more or
less how to balance this kind of like
user you know people don't like to walk
a lot but then other considerations is
also an interesting and challenging
problem um and so that's a relatively
simple optimization problem and we
talked about vehicle routing of course
we like uber and LIF like a lot of other
companies we're doing you know we're
Computing you know the basic routing
problems here I think risk-based routing
is a little different than traditional R
companies um we have a much better
understanding of risk because we want to
understand how safe our our autonomous
vehicles are and so we really know how
safe is every road uh for our vehicles
and we know um how often they get stuck
in different areas or how often you know
um they need assistance um and we also
have so we also have you know real time
information coming in about emergency
vehicles where they are stopped and
other situation of evolving on the road
and so there's a lot of you know
challenges in how to take that into
account in our routing cost into account
in routing so let's say I want to get to
this house and I know there's an
emergency scene here I I'd rather take
slightly longer path but that doesn't
cross that because then we know that the
vehicle will get stuck so taking into
account a lot of these kind of risk um
consideration in routing is also an
interesting and challenging problem and
how to balance those with you know time
and other you know costs in the on the
graph is interesting and we're still you
know dealing and solving these problems
um and indeed like taking into account a
lot of in interesting information about
risk um so that's it I just want to give
you you know a few you know nuggets
about you know problems that we're
dealing with and I'm happy to take any
questions as as I can answer yeah yeah
so I think the first two problems you
mentioned around optimal placement of
and then the charging problem aren't
those Intel links or do you end up
solving them because moving cars will
also kind of arguably reduce the
charging so do you end up solving them
concurrently or how do you go about what
you mean explain okay so the first
problem which is optimally place sorry
yeah I think the first problem where you
optimally place the the cars right by
moving them around you'll also actually
discharge right so that there'd be usage
and then the second problem we're
optimizing for utilization so I think
just curious are aren't those coupled
and if yes how do you solve them congr
they're coupled yeah so that's it's a
good question so basically typically
this problem this problem we solve with
a 24-hour Horizon and it has its own
objective function and this problem you
solve with like an hour Horizon it has a
different objective function and so how
do you tie them together that's a very
uh interesting question um
in
principle you can think about first
problem decides how many vehicle we are
going to basically get back to the
facility or deploy at you know a fairly
coar time scale uh but then the second
problem also has the ability
to tell like the first problem oh sorry
I have a lot of demand here I'm
canceling one of your you know a few of
your summoning right now and not doing
that and then I'm deciding to do this
you know deciding to do this kind of
assignment to to zones and then there
actually there's a third you know
problem which is what we do right now
with like existing uh requests so there
actually three tiers of problems here
and each of them can you know has some
cost of undoing what the other one
decided to do yeah thanks
yeah so the last problem you talked
about how is it different from
stochastic shs pass problem it is not
stochastic we don't have but no we're
not doing stochastic it's all shortest
path so it's just shortest path the
question is how do we set the weights
correctly yeah but stastics show the
pass problem is uh where for each Road
segment we have a distribution of delays
and you want to find say how when can I
leave so that with 95% probability on
it looks very similar because your risk
is really uh a stochastic variable on
delay yeah but for now I mean we could
solve it but as far as I know it would
be too slow you know we have latency
constraints H that basically means that
we need to do solve the regular shortest
[Music]
path you tell me you can solve it in
like five milliseconds I'll betic is a
hard yes
this is fascinating by the way uh my
question is more on the infrastructure
side so how are you collecting the data
that is being produced and are you
actually collecting data from Individual
cars and kind of uh conforming them
together joining them how how does that
work can you talk a little bit depends
on which data you're asking like so all
the measurements all the optimizations
you're doing let's say you have a one
hour Horizon where you have to make
certain decisions you have certain
states that I'm assuming you have
certain simulators that you're using but
you also have the current state that
you're collecting from your cars yes now
are you that streaming that data are you
actually putting it on the vehicle and
then somehow uh that gets uh you know
across multiple vehicles in a given
region and how does that work so a
vehicle basically stream data back we
need to be mindful of like how much data
but yeah they stream a lot of data back
to the cloud and there we aggregate that
and and solve this problem and then send
them back you know it's kind of like
orders go there pick up this one do that
uh but the these kind of computations
are not done on the car the car is just
busy you know navigating itself through
the road you know doing all the
perception and you know plan like
planning um but yeah and what it gets
from the cloud is just an order go from
point A to point B it can navigate by
itself um even if like you know our
cloud is down like the car can and
continue driving by itself to the
destination one one more question and I
guess then
uh a very simple question is that um so
when does it taking account of the
general traffic besides your autonomous
uh cars taking account in in what next
other cars in in in your consideration
of say Yeah in navigation in navigation
so it depends the navigation you know
the navigation from like Citywide no uh
it doesn't take into account other you
know vehicles around but when the car
needs to make the decision about do I
Lane change right now for the next 100
meters it takes into account of course
the other cars
around
yes all right what one more question
yeah thanks uh so right now you have
showed like different optimization
problems for the specific model of like
a uber an Uber right sharings uh
business model so what if the business
model changes do you consider other
business models if it's let's say car
rental or some other business model that
I haven't thought about or I mean Cruz
is also working on a delivery product
and that's definitely different but
delivery is you know very similar to
this like a customer trip is just you
know it's a trip that doesn't have a you
know a human inside just a food um but
for other's business model probably will
need a very different
system back system um yeah all right
let's uh thank or once
more